creating lasting memories this holiday
season 90 families received special
gifts at the annual
jingle jam event today bianca holman has
our story
here at the las vegas ballpark everyone
is on santa's nice list
the sixth annual jingle jam event put
smiles on everyone's faces
the community event was created by
mccall peck
to provide gifts to families who need a
little additional help during the
holiday season
kids made memories at the elf station
and the crafting station
and santa took socially distant pictures
spreading some holiday cheer
i think it's extremely important not
just because of helping the families and
helping our city and being community but
people want to still feel connected
so i think this year it's also just good
for the soul besides just receiving
and doing the charity thing being able
to have some taste of normalcy i think
is
so important every child left with a
wrapped gift a stuffed animal and a bike
donated by help of southern nevada
jingle jam has served more than 700
families over the years
reporting from summerlin bianca holman 8
news now